i'll meet you in the path
keep a close eye on him
you are covered mr cross i have
well what did he have to say for himself
riddles he's not the same man i knew
what's a fortunate outcome at least not
for my sister
it's natural that a place like this
should transform a man
i find myself anew in the silver of the
mirror
every morning now i take it you spoke to
captain whale in quebec city
this is mr charles duque and they speak
freely in front of him
and it's still good to meet you
i did not come here for tea and i prefer
molasses
not honey captain world did confirm your
ties to the company
well you see i am a man who speaks
plainly
they found lafarge's boy
now that is a relief but it would be if
he was still alive
we found him dead by the river
a shame his mother will be brought to
her knees
the boy's death is on your ledger no mr
gums
your mistake i have orders from captain
will to form a partnership with you
i know i find it disagreeable
i am a company man and an order is an
order after all
but i've been a simple barrel maker
my position within these walls hinges on
the good graces of intended affair
you see my time in the fiddle afforded
me some much-needed reflection i'm
keeping my beard low to the ground and
as such
i would point you in the direction of a
mr bill
selby he's out there forming alliances
perhaps
you're mr cross knows who his
whereabouts
good day
i handled the boy left the body for any
passing
fool to find better and looked like an
ex
it wasn't an accident charles
i see it in your eyes where sloppy work
should dissolve our partnership
that would be an unfortunate decision
it's my decision to make
before you make it i would like to know
why you neglected to tell the hudson's
bay men about the pistols
the pistols you're referring to
if i were going to betray you i already
would have
when i found that letter on your desk i
gleaned a lot about your arrangement to
supply
guns to the hudson's bicompany
but i must confess i am still curious on
a couple of points
it seems i have misjudged you
where are the pistols i don't know they
were to arm the iroquois so that they
could use them against the french
i know not what they were intended for i
traded for them
took my profit that's the end of the
story
good good
[Music]
you